que s'est-il vraiment passé ce 18 août
2013 à Joué les Tours alors que deux
policiers effectuaient un contrôle au
petit matin Guilen la jeune femme
visible sur cette vidéo était jugé
aujourd'hui pour violence sur un
dépositaire de l'autorité publique j'ai
eu peur pour mon ami que les policiers
interpelé dit-elle j'ai paniqué je n'ai
pas agrippé le policier j'ai tapoté sur
son épaule la présidente du tribunal
reprend pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas parti
alors que votre ami avait décidé de
coopérer avec la police pas de réponse
il y a il y a une perte de contrôle he
de ma cliente ça très clairement qu'elle
ne niit pas mais il y a une perte de
contrôle du policier ça effectivement
c'est inadmissible il va franchir la
ligne rouge et se rendre effectivement
coupable de violence volontaire aggravée
alors même qu'au début de son
intervention effectivement on pouvait
considérer qu'on était dans le cadre de
la légitime défense à la fin de son
intervention nous n'y sommes plus du
tout à la barre également l'un des
policiers loïqu que la défense a fait
cité à comparaître pour violence
aggravée le gardien de la paix de de 38
ans avait été entendu par la police des
polices qui ne l'avait pas inquiété on
parlait alors de légitime défense le
policier estime ne pas avoir fait de
ailes j'ai agi selon les techniques
licites qu'on nous enseigne je n'ai pas
frappé cette femme au visage j'ai
effectué des balayages avec mon bâton de
défense pour la repousser mais cette
femme était en furie c'est le procès de
la difficulté du travail de police parce
qu'on se rend compte que ces policiers
qui se retrouvent en infériorité
numérique euh confrontés à plusieurs
individus qui qui ne reculent devant
rien qui sont extrêmement
agressifs vivent vraiment une vie très
difficile une vie professionnelle très
difficile et c'est aussi le procès de la
société du respect que l'on doit à notre
police
et et de la du positionnement des
citoyens par rapport à l'autorité
publique à la barre également le
chauffeur de la voiture qui
comparaissait pour conduite sans permis
et en état d'ivresse devant la
présidente de la cour l'homme s'incline
si j'avais bien agi si je m'étais soumis
à ce contrôle de police
rien ne serait arrivé